This is continuing in Volume 1 from where we left off.
Louisa has just talked about receiving her first spiritual marriage and now she talks
about the consequences of that which is her new life as a spiritually married person.
My spouse Jesus gave me new rules in order to live more perfectly and since it has been
a long time I don't remember them so well, she says, "Therefore I will skip them"
and so it ended for that day.
Who can tell the finesse of love that Jesus made to my soul?
They were such and so many that it is impossible to describe them but I will try to say the
little that I remember.
Sometimes carrying me with him he would take me to paradise and there I would listen to
the canticles of the blessed and I could see the divinity which is totally amazing.
I could see the different choirs of angels and the orders of the saints all immersed in
the divinity of God, absorbed and identified with it.
It seemed to me that there were many lights around the throne of God which were more brilliant
than the sun and these lights displayed in clear notes all the virtues and the attributes
of God because God is light, that's one John one five.
By reflecting themselves in one of these lights they blessed in heaven would remain
enraptured in such a way that they could not arrive at penetrating the whole immensity
of that light therefore they would move to a second light without understanding all the
depth of the first one and so they keep on moving from one attribute of God to the other.
This is why heaven is continuously new all the time and totally fresh and yet one is
growing all the time in virtue and holiness.
So the blessed in heaven cannot understand God perfectly because the immensity, the greatness,
the sanctity of God is such, it's infinite of course, that a created mind cannot comprehend
an uncreated being, it's about that simple, he's infinite, we're finite.
So it would be like a drop of water being asked to explain what an ocean is, the drop
of water can be lost in the ocean but not be able to explain it.
Therefore in heaven the soul resembles God that one John three two we shall be like him
when we see him as we really is.
With this difference that God is that immense sun where the soul is a little sun, a little
light but who can in other words you have to be light to be in God and you have to be
loved to be in God.
But who can say all that can be understood in that blessed dwelling, it is impossible
to do it while the soul is in the prison of the body.
That's one Corinthians two nine I cannot see nor ear comprehend nor the heart understand
what God has prepared for those who love him, so you can't explain it.
It's impossible to do it while the soul is in the prison of the body, while one can feel
something in the mind, the lips do not find the terms to express it.
In other words, ordinary language cannot explain the things of the spirit.
It seems to me that it's like a child who begins to babble, he would like to say many
upon many things, but in the end he remains without being able to say even one clear word.
Therefore I will stop here without going any further.
I will just say that sometimes while finding myself in that blessed Fatherland, you'll
notice that it happened a number of times.
I would be strolling together with Jesus in the midst of the choirs of angels and saints.
Isn't that absolutely incredible?
So I want to give you Genesis three eight, that God walked or strolled with Adam in the
cool of the day.
That was when Adam was what in these writings are called Adam innocent before he rebelled
against God's will.
So I would be strolling together with Jesus in the midst of the choirs of angels and the
saints.
And since I was newly espoused, all the blessed would unite together to participate in the
joys of our marriage.
It seemed to me that they would forget their own contentment to occupy themselves with
ours, because everybody in heaven loves.
And love doesn't look at the self, love looks at the other.
And since everyone loved God infinitely, they're all wanting to celebrate the joy that Jesus
has in having a new beloved.
And sometimes Jesus would show me the saints saying, see this soul.
She is a triumph of my love.
My love has surpassed everything in her.
So Jesus boasted about Louisa to the saints in heaven, which is quite amazing.
Look at this soul.
She is a triumph of my love.
My love has surpassed everything in her.
Now you need to just keep remembering that Louisa is living in constant pain and suffering.
And she will suffer enormously from the deprivation of Jesus as well.
But this is the reality that she loves God more than anybody else.
Other times then he would make me stay in the place that I was going to be mine.
And he would say to me, here's your place.
Beside that, I want you to put John 14 verses 1 and 2 in my father's house.
There are many mentions, and there's one for you.
No one can take this place away from you.
At times, she said, I would reach the point of believing that I would no longer be going
back to the earth.
But in one simple instant, I would find myself locked up in the wall of the body.
Now the saints all suffered terribly when they had this experience of being taken out of
the body and then had to go back into it.
Who can tell how so very bitter this returning would be for me?
It seemed to me that in going from the things of heaven to the things of earth, everything
was rotten and insipid and bothering.
By comparison with heaven, that's absolutely true.
But those of us who don't know anything else thinks it's okay.
The things which delighted others so much were bitter for me.
The people most dear, most distinguished, such that others would do who knows what in
the order to be with them were indifferent to me and also bothering.
Only by looking at them as images of God did I seem to be able to even bear them.
Isn't that very interesting? Because she has seen such extraordinary realities in heaven.
Now what we have down here is absolutely nothing.
But my soul had lost any satisfaction.
Nothing would bring to it the slightest contentment and the pain I felt was such that I would
do nothing but cry and lament to my beloved Jesus.
Ah, my heart lived restless amidst continuous yearnings and desires for heaven, of course.
I felt more in heaven than on earth.
I felt in my interior something that consumed me continuously.
Now you'll hear more and more about this as you go on in the volumes and this is love
consuming Louisa.
So bitter and painful that it was for me having to continue to live.
So I want you to put two Corinthians 5 verses 1 to 10 there where St. Paul also desired
to die and be with the Lord.
But he decided that for the sake of his neighbor and for fulfilling the mission that God had
given to him that he would continue on earth.
I felt in my interior she said something that consumed me continuously so bitter and painful
it was for me having to continue to live.
But the obedience almost put a break on these pains and when she says the obedience she
means the commands coming from the church through the priest to her.
Commanding me in an absolute way not to desire to die since when the confessor would give
me the obedience only then was I to die.
And so the confessor realized that she wanted so badly to go to God that he actually forbade
her to even think about it.
For her now was the most dreadful obedience.
She considered it naturally enough completely irrational so would I in fact.
So in order to do the holy obedience I would do as much as I could to not think about heaven
because in my interior there was this continuous flow of desires and wanting to go to heaven.
So for the most part my heart calmed down but not completely.
I confess the truth I was very deficient in this but what could I do?
I could not restrain myself it was a true martyrdom for me.
My good Jesus would say to me can yourself what is it that makes you desire heaven so
much it's the fact that she's seen it and she's seen God that's what makes everybody
desire heaven.
The reason why the Lord doesn't allow you and me to have ecstasy is that ecstasy means
going out from yourself to God and seeing God you would want to die also.
And he wants us to live our full time of training upon the earth.
So Louisa would answer him it is that I want to be always united with you.
My soul can no longer bear being separated from you not for one day not even for a moment
therefore I want to come that is to die at any cost poor girl this is only volume one
she has 36 volumes to give us and she's going to be 64 years in the bed so appreciate the
depth of the difficulty that she has here if she knew how long she was going to have
to be in the bed I don't think she could have taken it.
Well then Jesus said if it's because of me I want to make you content I will come and
stay with you that means heaven comes to earth it's not yet time for earth to go to heaven
and then Louisa would say to him but then you leave me and I lose sight of you while
in heaven it's not so there I would never lose sight of you.
Sometimes Jesus also wanted to play what my book calls jokes now God never plays jokes
he plays love games because he is love and this is how while I would be in the midst
of these yearnings he would come all hurriedly and he would say to me do you want to come
and I would say to him where and he'd say to heaven and I would say you really mean that
and he'd say yeah hurry come don't delay and I would say well then let's go but I fear
you want to make fun of me in other words you're testing me to see will I remain obedient
to the call I have been given to serve you on the earth you see or happy I would be then
thinking of getting to leave the earth life itself life seemed to be asleep to me and
suffering seemed very little as we would reach a high point of heaven I would hear the singing
of the blessed I would solicit Jesus to introduce me quickly into that blessed dwelling but Jesus
would begin to slow down in my interior I would start to suspect that it wasn't true
who knows I would say if this is not a game that he's playing with me every now and then
I would say to him my Jesus dear hurry up and he would say to me in a way a little longer
let us go down on the earth again see out there there is a sinner who is about to be lost
now what he's trying to do is give her motivation to come back to the earth and to carry on
with her mission so if she only stays with her personal desires she only wants to go
to heaven but of course she would never receive the reward that was prepared for her in heaven
if she carried if she didn't carry out her mission out there he said there is a sinner
who's about to be lost let us go who knows whether he might convert let us pray together
to the eternal Father that he may use mercy on him don't you want him to be saved are
you not ready to suffer any pain for this salvation of even one soul because that was
the way Jesus was that he would suffer anything for one soul and Louisa said yes anything you
want me to suffer I am ready as long as you save him so we would go to that sinner we
would try to convince him we would place the most powerful reasons before his mind to make
him surrender but in vain then all afflicted Jesus would say to me my spouse return to
your body once again take upon yourself the pains destined for him now beside that I want
to give you John 13 34 to 35 you are to love one another in the same way as I loved you
when Jesus loved us by sacrificing everything in himself in order to save us and Philippians
chapter two verses one to eleven as well chapter two one two eleven that tells us that Jesus
left the glory of his Godhead behind and took on humanity and was humbler than us even to
accepting death on a cross just to save us so he left the glory of heaven to come into
this terrible conflict in order to save us and so he's asking Louisa if she would agree
to do what he did because she has to be a person who imitates everything in his life so if you
would take upon yourself the pains destined for him either purgatory or hell in this way being
appeased the divine justice will use mercy on him in other words if you want this soul to be saved
there is a price to pay you've seen it for yourself words have not shaken him and not even
reasons there's nothing left but pains which are the most powerful means in order to satisfy
justice and to make the sinner surrender so here Jesus is teaching Louisa that sorrow and
suffering are the only teachers on this earth that make us surrender and make us even think
because until we are stopped by sorrow and suffering we just continue on and on and on in the way we
were going so Louisa said he would bring me once again into my body who can tell the sufferings I
would receive only the Lord knows who has been the witness of it so after a few days then he would
make me see that soul converted and saved in other words it was worth the effort oh how happy
was Jesus and she said I was as well then she continues who can tell how many times Jesus played
these games with me when we would reach the point of entering heaven and sometimes even after entering
he would say that he had not let me have the obedience from the confessor and therefore I
should go back to the earth now he's trying to teach her to be completely aware of the fact
that she's under the guidance of the church and that even when she's dealing with him that that
obedience and that guidance is not gone away and so she is obligated to go and obey and this is
what she finds extremely bitter because she says to the Lord when I'm with you surely none of that
applies and he says no no it applies he would say that he had not given let me have the obedience
from the confessor and therefore I would have to go back to the earth and I would say to him
as long as I was with the confessor I was obliged to obey him but now that I am with you I'm only
so obliged to obey you because you are the first among all and he would say oh no no no I want you
to obey the confessor in other words her time on the earth is not complete then not to make it too
long now one pretext and then another he'd make me go back to the earth and she was finding this
very very difficult getting as far as heaven and then having to go back and getting as far as heaven
again these love games were very painful for me it is enough to say that I became
impertinent now the dictionary meaning for that word is rude and insolent but the thing is you can't
be living at the level that Louisa is living at and be rude and insolent God would go immediately
because unholyness cannot enter the presence of God so it means that that you know her reactions
became a bit inappropriate so much so that in order to chastise my inappropriateness the Lord
no longer allowed these games to happen in other words she reacted negatively she couldn't take it
so he stopped but that's how we do in relationships as well if we make a move and the person can't
take it we back off don't we so in the next paragraph we have her second marriage which is in heaven
which is completely unprecedented you won't find it in any other saints lives I'd spent about three
years in this state already described she said continuing to remain in bed when one morning Jesus
made me understand that he wanted to renew the marriage not on earth because of the spiritual
marriage as the first time but in heaven in the presence of the celestial court this is completely
unprecedented this is off the rich to scale completely and that I should remain prepared for a grace
that is so great I did as much as I could in order to dispose myself she said but since I'm so miserable
and insufficient in doing any shadow of good that's John 15 five without me you can do nothing the
hand of the divine maker was needed in order to dispose me that's Philippians 4 13 but I can do
all things in Christ who gives me the strength so at the hand of the divine maker was needed in
order to dispose me because by myself I would never have managed to purify my soul one morning
it was the eve of the nativity of Mary Most Holy which would be September the 8th my always good
Jesus himself came to dispose me he did nothing but come and go continuously he would speak to me
about faith and then he would leave me and I would feel a life of faith being infused into my soul
because the words of Jesus are what John of the Cross calls substantive words they contained life
and Jesus himself says that his words are creative so this substantive word put into you actually
creates what he actually says so he created this new level of life of faith in her as rough as I
felt before at these words of Jesus I would feel my soul become very light that means much more
spiritualized in such a way as to penetrate into God you see God is most pure spirit and the reason
why we can't approach him is that we're very heavy flesh but when we are more and more spiritualized
we become more and more able to enter into that presence and when we get to the higher volumes
Jesus will say that Louisa has been transformed into light will God is light so that's that's the miracle
that happens in heaven but he wants it to happen on earth through the divine will that we would be
transformed into light and therefore be able to be completely one with God so she said I would feel
my soul become very light in such a way as to penetrate into God and I would contemplate first
his power then his sanctity his goodness and so on my soul would remain stupefied and in a sea of
stupefaction meaning that you're dealing with something there's no way your mind can comprehend
I would say powerful God what power is not undone before you immense sanctity of God what other
sanctity as sublime as it may be would dare to even appear in your presence now that's your Hebrews
12 14 nothing unholy or unworthy can ever enter the presence of God and before his presence what we
call holiness and sanctity is nothing absolutely nothing we just don't have any capacity to understand
the greatness of the holiness of God then I would feel myself descend into myself and I would see
my own nothingness the non-entity of earthly things now everything is nothing before God that's
Samate Lord what is man that you would even care for him you've made the entire universe just with
your word and yet you made us little less than a God it's total mystery so the secret that the
Lord wants to give to us as we enter into this divine will journey is that if we just recognize
our nothingness and continuously throw our nothingness into his allness then he can work with us
because he only creates out of nothing and so if there's something of me there he can do nothing
with it it's it's useless material to him so it would be like an artist throwing something away
that's useless but if I give him my nothingness yes he can use that so Louisa said I could see
my nothingness the non-entity of earthly things and everything is nothing before God I would see
myself as a little worm all full of dust climbing up in order to take a few steps it would take
nothing to destroy me and someone who would trample me underfoot and I would be undone because that's
the image of the worm and seeing myself so ugly I almost would not dare to go to God but his greatness
would make itself present before me before my mind and I would feel drawn as though by a magnet to
go to him that one Peter five nine that we bow before the power of God and I would say to myself
if he is holy he's also merciful if he is powerful he also contains full and highest goodness within
himself that's Luke 18 20 it seemed to me that goodness surrounded him on the outside and inundated
him from within so I would contemplate the goodness of God it seemed to me that it would surpass
all other attributes but then looking at the others I would see them all equal among themselves
immense immeasurable and incomprehensible to human nature while my soul would be in this state
Jesus would come back and speak to me about hope so now he's going to deal with the three theological
virtues which are absolutely essential if we're going to be living in union with God I remember
something confusingly because after so much time it's impossible to remember clearly but in order
to do the obey as I am asked I'll say what I can so in this first section we're going to talk about
faith and that faith is the sight of your soul if there's no faith you're blind so going back to
faith the first theological virtue Jesus would say in order to obtain you must believe
for the atheist who thinks God isn't there do you think does any prayer no do you think does
any hope no does he need to love no he's neither faith hope nor love utterly tragic
just as for the head without the sight of the eyes everything is darkness everything is confusion
so much so that if one wanted to walk he would stumble at one point and then at another and you'd
end up falling completely the same with the soul without faith so that's mark 11 24 so it's the same
with the soul without faith she does nothing but go from precipice to precipice spiritually speaking
but faith serves as sight for the soul and as light which guides her to eternal life
Matthew 6 22 23 now what is this light of faith nourished by it's nourished by hope
now what is the substance of this light of faith I want to give you Sam 119 verse 105
what is the substance of this light of faith and the nourishment of hope it's charity
so you see that the three theological virtues are very much bound together they cannot be separated
all of these three virtues are grafted to one another in such a way that one cannot be without
the other in fact what good comes to man from believing in immense riches of faith if he does
not have hope for them to to reach so that he can reach out and receive them he will look at them
yes but with an indifferent eye because he knows that they don't belong to him but hope provides the
light of faith with wings and by hoping in the merits of Jesus Christ he looks at them as his own
and he comes to love them so I want to give you Isaiah 40 31 they that wait upon the Lord shall
renew their strength they shall mount up with wings like the eagle they shall run and not be weary
they shall walk and not faint those who can hope in the Lord and can reach out for all that God
offers to them they're the ones who can achieve everything spiritually so the next one is hope
and so if you want a little heading for this hope is the wings of faith faith is the eyes or
the sight for the soul hope is the wings of faith hope Jesus said provides the soul with the garment
of fortitude almost of iron in such a way that with all their arrows the enemies cannot wound her
not only this but they cannot cause even the slightest disturbance because they can't get through
everything is tranquility in her everything is peace that's Philippians 4 7 that's the peace that
passes all understanding and guides the heart and the mind in Christ Jesus and this peace Jesus is
going to insist that we must work towards that we must work to keep it and we mustn't allow anything
under any circumstances to disturb it so hope provides the soul with the garment of fortitude
in such a way that all the arrows of the enemies cannot wound her not only this but they can't even
cause the slightest disturbance everything is tranquility in her and everything is peace
oh it is beautiful to see this soul invested with beautiful hope all cleaving to her beloved
all distrustful of herself but trustful in God that's Ephesians chapter 6 verses 4 to 10
she challenges the fiercest enemy she's queen of her passions that's all of your emotions
she regulates all of her interior her inclinations her desires her heartbeats her thoughts
with such mastery that Jesus himself remains enamored because he sees that this soul operates
with such courage and strength so 2 Corinthians 10 verses 4 to 5 and Colossians 1 27
but the soul draws all of this from Jesus and places all her hope in him so much so
that in seeing this firm hope Jesus cannot deny anything to this soul so let me give you a number
of references for that Revelation 2 chapter 2 verse 7 verse 11 verse 17 verse 26
Revelation chapter 3 verses 5 12 and 21 and Revelation 21 7 and you'll see all the things
that the Lord gives us when we have reached out in hope for him I also want to give you Romans 15
verses 4 and 13 now while Jesus would speak about hope he would withdraw a little leaving a light
in my intellect that means infused knowledge and understanding who can tell what I understood about
hope if all the other virtues serve to embellish the soul but can make a stagger and render us in
constant hope instead renders the soul firm and stable like those high mountains which cannot be
moved a tiny bit it seems to me that it happens to the soul invested with hope as to certain very
high mountains all the intemperances of the air cannot do any harm to these mountains
neither snow nor winds nor heat can penetrate into them whatever thing might be placed on their top
one can be sure of finding it there where it was put even a hundred or a thousand years hence
just so is the soul cloted with hope nothing can do her harm neither tribulation nor poverty
nor do all the various accidents of life dismay her in one instant she says to herself I can do
everything I can bear everything I can suffer everything hoping in Jesus who forms the object of my hopes
there's your Philippians 4 13 again I can do it in him I cannot do it outside of him
hope renders the soul almost omnipotent invincible and it administers to her the final perseverance
so much so that only then does she cease to hope and to persevere when she has taken possession
of the kingdom of heaven so here Jesus is saying that the virtue of holy hope is what brings us to
the the harbor of eternal life then only then when she arrives to take possession of her kingdom does
she lay down hope and plunges all of herself into the immense and eternal ocean of divine love
so the third one now is charity or divine love faith hope and charity and I want to give you one
Corinthians 13 verses 1 to 13 love is like this love is not like that and so on and verse 13 is
very important because it says and the gracious of these is love finally it says there's faith
hope and love but the gracious of these is love so now we're coming to the gracious of the theological
virtues while my soul would dissolve in the immense sea of hope my beloved Jesus would come back and
speak to me about charity now forget about the way the word charity is used nowadays this is
caritas this is agape this is divine love this is not human love and this is not at charity as we
say nowadays faith and hope give way to agape or caritas and charity connects all the rest of
the other two together in such a way as to make them one while they are three and here it is all
my spouse veiled in the three theological virtues the trinity of divine persons faith hope and love
father son and holy spirit separate together one and permanent isn't that absolutely fantastic
so faith hope and love power wisdom and love creator redeemer sanctifier father son and holy
spirit we're talking about the same triune mystery all the time it's just incredible so in order to
have this high union with god we naturally have to have these three virtues which allow god to find
himself in us and express himself in us and through us then Jesus continued if faith makes one believe
and hope makes one hope charity makes one love if faith is light and serves as the site of the soul
and hope which is the nourishment of faith provides the souls with courage peace perseverance and all
the rest charity which is the substance of this light and of this nourishment is like that most
sweet and fragrant ointment which penetrating everywhere relieves and soothes the pains of life
this unction so it's one Corinthians thirteen eight and one john four seven that god is love
so this is the unction of the spirit operating in us because the holy spirit is the love of god
charity makes suffering sweet we would say bearable and makes one reach the point even of desiring it
because of what you can do with it you can save so many souls the soul who possesses charity diffuses
fragrance everywhere her works all done out of love give off the most pleasing order that's revelation
eight four and what is this order it is the order of god himself the church uses the language of the
order of sanctity and jesus says it's the order of god himself the other virtues render the soul
solitary Colossians 3 14 and almost unrefined with creatures but charity on the other hand
being the substance that unites unites the heart but where it unites them in god
being a most fragrant ointment or unction charity spreads everywhere and with everyone
charity makes one suffer the most ruthless torments with joy
Matthew 5 10 Hebrews 12 2 and one reaches the point of not being able to be without suffering
louisa has already reached that point and when she sees herself deprived of it she says to her
spouse sustain me with the fruits which is suffering the song of songs to five but the song of song
says sustain me with apples apple and the apple is a symbol of love and jesus is saying that the
greatest witness that we can give is to actually want the suffering for love to allow love to be
resurrected in the souls of others sustain me with the fruits which is suffering because i'm
languishing with love and where else can i show you my love other than by suffering from you and
therefore through this in giving birth to souls charity burns and consumes all things that's your
Hebrews 12 29 our god is a consuming fire charity burns consumes all other things even the virtues
themselves and turns them all into itself so in the very early stages of the spiritual life
people can talk about patience and kindness and goodness and this and that and the other
but when they really hit the jackpot excuse my language then everything is love and everything
becomes love and love is the only issue love is the center of everything and love is it because
god is love in some it's like a queen who wants to reign everywhere and does not want to surrender
to anyone luisa said who can tell what remained after this teaching of jesus i will just say that
such yearning for suffering ignited within me and not just yearning but i feel as though an infusion
in me like something natural such that i believe is the greatest disgrace not to suffer now this
revelation has been given to luisa specifically because she's being called to be a victim soul
and we will hear in volume six that jesus will tell her that the whole of europe is resting on her
shoulders and that if she doesn't make reparation for europe in the two world wars that things would
be infinitely worse so that is why she's being drawn in this particular direction not everybody
is drawn to love suffering this way after this on that morning in order to dispose my heart more
jesus spoke about the annihilation of myself that means you really really set aside your own will
and your own ego and you let a divine love be born in you and divine will rule and find its
home in you that's what this journey is all about it's not about saying prayers it's not about doing
fancy things it's not about great actions it's not about that it's about putting ourselves aside
completely so that god can take off his reign in us and through us that he can live on the earth
so after this on that morning in order to dispose my heart more jesus spoke about the
annihilation of myself he also spoke about the immense desire which i was to excite within me
in order to dispose myself to receive that grace in other words if god is going to offer you something
you have to want it if you don't want it it's an insult to him somebody could offer you thousand
pounds or dollars or euros or whatever but if you don't want it the giver is not going to be
able to actually gift you and the giver will be left feeling absolutely terrible and jesus wants
to give us riches beyond which money cannot even express but he needs us to want what god is offering
to us and to want the holiness that he wants us to have so he told me that desire makes up for
the lact and the imperfections that we may have in the soul it is like a mantle that covers everything
but this was not a simple teaching it was an infusion in me that he was saying he was actually
putting the grace within her he was actually enabling her to reach the heights that she was to
reach now about this thing about the desire making up for the lact if you have studied the life of
saint arrays of lissure she locked herself up in caramelite convent to make reparation for
priests and for the church and but she reached a level of love that she wanted to be a priest she
wanted to be a missionary she wanted to be a teacher she wanted to be this and that and the other
anything that would serve the lord and the lord took her desire as the action done now in the divine
will jesus says the same thing to us if you desire it i will do it would you have to really want it
so now we come to the great event the second marriage of louisa picaretta to jesus this time
the marriage is in heaven this is the next paragraph
while my soul was exciting itself with ardent yearnings for receiving the grace that jesus
himself wanted to give me jesus came back and transported me outside of myself up to paradise
and there in the presence of the most holy trinity and of all the celestial court he renewed the
marriage did jesus want this oh absolutely did he want somebody on the earth who really really
really loved him absolutely did he want somebody on the earth to give herself totally to him to
fulfill jus around me six four to ten that you would love the lord with all your heart all your soul
all your mind and all your being absolutely he wants it from all of us
so he renewed the marriage jesus put out a ring adorned with three precious stones white red and
green and he gave it to the father who blessed it and gave it back to the son again the holy spirit
the spouse took my right hand and jesus placed the ring on my right finger notice the right hand the
left hand is for human marriages and the right hand is for consecration to god and so i just want
you to note this point then i was admitted to the kiss of all three divine persons and each of them
blessed me so i want to give you john 17 verses 4 to 8 so a greater grace than this you couldn't
have you couldn't even imagine who can tell my confusion when i found myself before the most
holy trinity i will just say that as soon as i found myself in their presence i felt flat on the
ground revelation 117 that's where st john fainted in front of the immense glory of jesus in the
resurrection i felt flat on the ground and i would have remained there if it wasn't for jesus who
encouraged me to go into their presence so much was the light and the sanctity of god it creates
terror in us because we're the exact opposite and this is where people go to hell of their own volition
when after death they are confronted with this immense incredible sanctity and purity of god
and they realize they're not fit to be there at all that's when souls plunge themselves into
pargotry or hell depending on which is the right place but they do it themselves all they have to
do is come into this unbelievable extraordinary presence of god and you couldn't stay you have
to be like him to stay and so she said she couldn't have done anything unless jesus had encouraged her
to go into their presence so much was the light and the sanctity of god i'm only saying this the
other things i will leave out she says because i remember them confusedly so i want to give you
two Corinthians 10 verses 1 to 10 where st paul talks about being caught up into the third heaven
and not being able to say what happened either after this i remember that a few days past and i
received communion i lost consciousness that means she went into ecstasy and i saw present before me
the most holy trinity whom i had seen in heaven now she sees it in the most holy eucharist i immediately
prostrated myself in their presence i adored them and i confessed my nothingness that is the correct
response to god i remember that i felt so plunged within myself that i did not dare to utter a single
word when a voice came from their midst and said do not fear pluck up courage we have come to confirm
you as our own and to take possession of your heart so what you have in the first paragraph there
was the actual marriage that took place and then three days later louise experiences god coming
to actually take possession of her soul in other words she was given three days to think about it
three days grace she could have gone back on it but because she didn't they came to take possession
so this would confirm her in grace of course as well and would make her salvation assured
while this voice was saying this i saw that the most holy trinity descended into my heart
and took possession of it and there they formed their dwelling one Corinthians 3 16
and also one Corinthians 6 16 you are the dwelling place of god
who can tell the change that occurred in me i felt divinized it was no longer i who lived now
that's Galatians 220 i no longer live christ lives in me it was no longer i who lived but they were
living in me which is exactly what Paul says in Galatians 220 it seemed to me that my body was
like a residence that's your one Corinthians 3 16 you're the temple of god and that the living god
was residing in me because i could feel sensibly their real presence in my interior you need to
underline all of this this is incredibly important so you can call louise a temple of god because
god is dwelling in her you can call her a tabernacle because god is dwelling in her i could hear their
voice clearly she said coming from within my interior and resounding at in the ears of my body
it seemed it happened precisely as when people are speaking within a room and their voices can be
heard clearly and distinctly also on the outside so i want to give you their Luke 17 21 the kingdom
of god is within you so louise actually experiences this she feels it she doesn't just know it in some
kind of a theoretical way she actually experiences its reality from that moment on i no longer had
the need to go in search of him somewhere else in order to find him but i could find him here
inside of my own heart and when sometimes he would hide and i would go and search of jesus wandering
around heaven and earth searching for my highest and only good while i would be in the heat of my
tears and in the intensity of my yearnings amid unoperable pains for having lost him that's sam 63
versus one to eight jesus would come out from within my interior and say to me i'm here i'm inside of
you don't look for me anywhere else between the surprise and the contentment for having found him
i would say to him my jesus how is it for the entire morning you made me go round and round in
order to find you and you're here you could at least tell me but then she has experienced it she's
supposed to remember so i would not have to be so worked up my sweet good my dear life take a look
at how tired i am i feel as if i have no more strength i feel faint or please sustain me with
your arms for i feel i am dying and so jesus would take me in his arms and would make me rest and
while resting i would feel my strength being restored now that's sam one three one my soul is like a
weaned child on its mother's lap other times in this hiding of jesus and my going around looking
in search of him now she will continue to do that even though she knows he's within it's not going
to cure her when he would make himself felt within me and then come out from within me i would find
not jesus alone but all three divine persons that's exactly what she experienced in this marriage
and she would experience them in the form sometimes of three children gracious and immensely beautiful
and then with one single body and three distinct heads but resembling each other all three of them
attractive now this is merely an image to help her weakness that this three is one
an image that i give to people to explain the three and one is that if you take three lighted
candles now it's not the wact i'm interested in is the flame if you put those three flames together
they will become one flame they don't occupy three times the space they occupy the same space as the
one but you can pull two of the candles out and you've got three if you put them back you get one
and so it's to try and get across this image to louisa of the three and one she sees them as three
children or one with three heads who could tell my contentment she says especially when i would see
the three children whom i would hold all three of them in my arms i would kiss one and then the other
and receive their kisses one would lean on my shoulder another on it the other shoulder and
another would remain in front of me and while delighting in them i would go about looking at
them and to my amazement from three i would find one so here again i give you genesis 18 from verse
one abraham meeting the three angels at the oak of moray before his intercession for sartem and gomara
and that while he experienced them as three and he fed them as three at the same time there was
only one voice and one message and when he got the one voice and the one message he said he knew he
was it was the lord another amazement for me is that i would be with the three children when i
would be with the three children was that each of them would weigh as much as the three of them together
this is this is the bit about the the candle flame as well i would feel as much love for one
as for the three of them and for all three of them together each one of them attracted me in the same
way now in the eucharistic miracles that have happened all down the centuries the same phenomenon
has been noticed in one of these miracles there were i think either three or five blobs of blood
and when the scientists examined them they were astounded to find let's say five because
you know five is a good number that the five would weigh the same as one they couldn't understand
because it doesn't fit science at all and they said this was some kind of a a phenomenon belonging
to another world in order to speak about these marriages louisa said i have to skip over a few
things for i was following the thread and now i will tell them she now comes to what we call her
third marriage and that's marriage to the cross of christ this is completely unique you'll never
hear about it in any other person it just didn't happen going back to the beginning she said when
jesus would dain to come he would speak to me very often about his passion and he would take care
in disposing my soul to the imitation of his life and of his pains telling me that in addition to
the marriage which is mentioned above that we had one more left to do and that was the third marriage
marriage to the cross or the marriage of the cross i remember that he would say my spouse virtues
become weak if they're not strengthened and fortified by the grafting of the cross
before my coming upon the earth pains, confusions, disgrace, calumnese, sufferings, poverty, illnesses
and especially the cross were considered dishonors but from the moment they were born by me they were
all sanctified and divinized by my contact that's very very important they all changed their appearance
becoming sweet and pleasant and the soul who has the good of having some of them receives honor
and this because she has received the vestment of me the son of god the the vestment of our high
priest is the cross only those who look and stop at the cortex that's the outer shell of the cross
experience the country finding it bitter they are disgusted by it they complain as if someone had
done wrong to them but those who penetrate into the mystery of the cross finding it enjoyable
form their happiness in it that's Hebrews 12-2 for the joy that was set before him he endured
the cross despising the shame my beloved daughter i yearn for nothing else but to crucify you body
and soul on awful thing to hear but that was in fact what louise had to experience if she was to
have full and complete identification with christ and while he would say this i would feel such
infusion and yearnings for being crucified with christ jesus that i would often repeat my jesus
my love hurry crucify me with you i want to give you Galatians 219 Galatians 524 and Galatians 614
where paul tells us to glory and the cross of our lord jesus christ
which crucifies us to the world and when he would come back the first thing i would say to him
which seemed to be the most important to me were these sorrow for my sins and the grace of being
crucified with him it seemed to me that if i obtained this i would obtain everything
then one morning my most beloved jesus made himself present before me in the form of a crucifix
and told me that he wanted to crucify me with him now valipians 413 i can do all things in christ
john 15 5 i can do nothing without him so to be crucified with him as he was saying this i saw
that rays of light were coming out from his most holy wounds and within those rays nails
which were coming towards me at that moment i don't know why though i desired so much to be
crucified with him and feel consumed i was caught by a great fear that made me tremble from head to
foot i felt such annihilation of myself i saw myself so unworthy to receive that grace that i did not
dare to say lord crucify me with you jesus seemed to be suspended waiting for my will god will never
go against your will he's the one who gave you free will and so if you don't concede your willingness
to him he won't go outside of that i felt such unworthiness jesus seemed to be suspended waiting
for my will who can tell how ardently i desired him within the intimate part of my soul though at
the same time i saw myself so unworthy my nature was frightened and trembled but while i was in this
state my beloved jesus through the intellect solicited me to accept then with all of my heart i said
to him my spouse crucified for me i pray you to concede me the grace to be crucified and at the
same time not allow any external sign to appear on the outside so she she's going to be given the
stig matter but it's not going to appear on the outside she wants it to be completely hidden yes
give me the suffering give me the wounds let me have everything but let everything be hidden
between me and you so this is unseen stig matter i'm going to stop there for the moment